so I went to Carnegie Mellon Carnegie
Tech for me my high school central was
right next door we dreamt of going to
Carnegie Tech because our directors our
choreographers or set builders or often
Carnegie Tech the theater is still the
theatre school in the country I have a
school I have a school in - and the
teachers special makeup effects we just
celebrated our 16th year anniversary and
they come from all over the world
there's no formula for success but
here's what works
learn how first of all learn how and
photograph absolutely everything we do
and put those portfolios in front of
people that can help or hire you so when
you're in the right place at the right
time be ready you know that's what
happened to me the second thing was
showing my portfolio to Carnegie Mellon
University based on the portfolio I got
a letter we're pleased to announce that
you are accepted in the acting directing
program we're also pleased to announce
that you will teach Tuesdays and
Thursdays under a fellowship program now
I'm gonna undergraduate fellowships are
for graduates so I was the first
undergraduate to get a full fellowships
that was mind blowing to me to actually
be in this place that we all dreamed of
going I mean I was teaching students
that I was in classes with when I was
still at Carnegie Mellon and I got a
telegram from George we have another gig
start thinking nice to kill people and
that was Dawn of the Dead
I'm not turning that down it's a sequel
to a night of a living day I'm going to
have to take a leave of absence from CMU
in order to prepare and then do the
movie but you know it didn't work out
because after Dawn of the Dead i kept
getting scripts I got Friday the 13th
the the 80s decade was upon me and that
was the splatter decade that was when I
was the king of gore The Wizard of gore
because you know the burning Friday the
13th the Prowler these are all the
splatter films and I did during the 80s
that was my reputation until creep show
creep show is when I got to do creatures
like fluffy and that was characters and
you know and then Texas Chainsaw was
old-age makeups on grandpa so that
wasn't that was my opportunity to not do
gore but to do characters and creatures
and sophisticated makeups I never
thought I would get at a CMU because
back when I was in high school CMU was
like you know
Xander doodling it was the Lost Horizon
it was unattainable